well our biggest worry at the moment is
that is actually staffing and we're
seeing that in terms of increased staff
sickness rates and there's simple
measures which could be done in fact
we've written to the uk health uh
security agency uh an open letter asking
for an upgrade in their outdated ppe uh
to provide fp3 masks which are better
protection um than it's currently
available the kind of standard surgical
mask you're seeing on camera there uh
wouldn't be acceptable on a german bus
you'd use an fb2 mask um and you know
given those staff sickness rates we are
worried as as we go into the new year um
how we're going to manage and that is
you know causing a lot of stress amongst
staff in in all groups not just doctors
but nursing staff as well
okay let's break this down so staff
sickness this is
staff in the hospitals who are actually
getting covet
uh
for covered and non-competitive related
reasons and that's certainly the k you
know case at the moment in london which
is very much the epicenter
of of the omicron
uh situation at the moment and in fact
overnight i just had an email from a
colleague of mine um you were mentioning
earlier about the problems
in terms of uh pilots uh and less
flights okay got staff trying to fly
back um you know who who won't be at
work next week basically because their
flights have been delayed so it's
detecting every single piece of the
puzzle yeah do you have any figures on
how many um members of staff
are
isolating i'm assuming that's assuming
that's what they're doing if they've got
cover 19 or
they can't come to work if they're ill
with something else do you have any
figures of how many staff can't come to
work uh i can't give that figure off the
top of my head from my own trust for
example but uh you know it we're
definitely seeing that within uh london
and elsewhere basically and uh you know
we were already seeing that within
birmingham where i work basically um so
you know it it is it is a big issue and
we know also
in terms of itu staff uh our staffing
levels are not the same as they were um
a year ago um and that you know when we
talk about bed numbers and things it's
actually you need to understand the
staff numbers as much as anything
actually
what staff sorry was that i didn't catch
that in terms of critical care staff
so now if you look at the staffing
levels and the issues surrounding
staffing levels that you have at the
moment and you compare them to say
january this year how do they compare
when i speak to my colleagues in
critical care they all tell me they've
got less nursing stuff than they had 12
months ago
and when you look at the data that boss
johnson was presented with around
the omicron variant this wasn't included
was it the staff shortages
uh no but i mean i think
i mean i think it's interesting
each of the different parts of the uk
are doing things differently and
presumably they're looking at exactly
the same data steps
i think that speaks volumes
right so okay so let's look at what he
was presented with case rates
hospitalizations how sick people are how
long they are staying in hospital
um with omicron do you think if there
were new restrictions in england it
would have an effect on the staff
shortages that you're seeing
well
we are where we are you know these are
decisions which should have been made um
a couple of weeks ago and
you know i suppose what we in the
doctors association are worried about
our members right now there's many
things we don't know about omicron okay
but there's things we do know and we
knew it's more transmissible so it
logically makes sense to update
the pp guidance because we know who you
know covert is airborne
and to provide better protections for
staff to reduce safe sickness rates it's
that simple
okay dr david nicholl we're going to
leave it there but thank you for talking
to us
thank you